listen foxes alert more breaking news
tonight Fox News can confirm that the
deputy AG rod Rosenstein is expected to
leave the Department of Justice in
mid-march
now this comes on the heels of bombshell
revelations relating to his conduct
while at the department you got to
remember back in 2016 the small group of
high-ranking unelected unaccountable
bureaucrats with a dark political agenda
they sought to undermine then candidate
then president-elect and ultimately undo
the election of We the People
first they rigged and fixed the Hillary
Clinton email investigation so she would
not be charged with the Espionage Act
felonies and of course obstruction of
justice because we can all delete 33,000
subpoenaed emails right and now we're
learning that this agenda was even
deeper than we ever realized with that
so-called insurance policy put in place
to bludgeon President Trump should he
win put in place by the very people that
believed trope voters were smelly
Walmart people Hillary's should win a
hundred million a zero that's why they
saved their favorite candidate anyone
else would have been charged and
according to disgraced FBI official
Andrew McCabe he's saying in May 2017
there were actual discussions with
deputy AG rod Rosenstein to wear a wire
in meetings with the president in the
hopes of invoking the 25th amendment
were they planning on a warrant here
takedown a duly elected
commander-in-chief because their chosen
candidate lost and as her own catherine
herridge reports two so-called unnamed
cabinet members or actually on board
with this insane plan coup and while
Rosen Stein has offered a carefully
worded denial McCabe says that it was
rod Rosen Stein who quote was absolutely
serious about recording the president
now I want to be very clear it doesn't
matter if you're a Democrat Republican
liberal conservative here this abuse of
power should scare everybody this almost
happened in the United States of America
we're not a Banana Republic those that
are shouting allowed us that we need to
preserve our institutions well they're
the biggest offenders of weaponizing the
powerful tools
of intelligence they thought they knew
better than the American people first it
was about stealing an election stopping
Trump from becoming president then
staging a coup to remove a duly elected
president to pursue their own
self-serving agenda they're smarter than
us smelly Walmart people you know which
was to preserve the swamp in the deep
state and it's all on full display
because now they're starting to turn on
each other because now they're panicking
and they know they got caught remember
call me Rosenstein Andrew McCabe Sally
eighths all of them signed off on
Hillary Clinton's FISA warrant
application used in Hillary's bought and
paid for unverified uncorroborated phony
Russian research and then not only
propagandize and lied to the american
people to help hillary win well then of
course they used it as the basis bulk of
information in a FISA application four
times they certified that that phony
bought and paid for dossier was verified
we now know it was never verified and
that they made material false statements
to a FISA court denying a fellow
American his constitutional rights even
the dossiers author under oath in Great
Britain and an interrogatories that I
don't know if any of this is true it's
50/50 matru intelligence they used the
Clinton bought and paid for Russian lies
they first used it to lie to you and
manipulate you and propagandize you the
American people before the election to
help Hillary and then of course the spy
on the Trump campaign before and after
the election then to launch this phony
witch-hunt Muller probe to cover their
own misdeeds their insurance policy
after the president was rightly firing
Comey and all the while Rosenstein
apparently scheming to surveil the
president and vote the 25th amendment to
tape him Attorney General mr. Barr it's
up to you to stand on the Constitution
to stop this type of corruption to
reform this great agency that we all
love and that is the FBI not these guys
but you owe it to the rank-and-file
those guys that do the honest work every
day and hold these individuals in the
upper echelon accountable and
re-establish credibility to the
embattled FBI and DOJ Kimberly Strasse
Wall Street Journal says quote that's
the Justice Department mr. Barr arrives
to lead a hot mess of finger-pointing
leaks planetpress narratives obstruction
and extraordinary self-righteousness
it's long overdue for decisive action in
ending this dysfunction and this
corruption of course these major
revelations are being ignored by
Democrats and they're willing
accomplices in the hate Trump media
they're even laying the groundwork for
more investigations into their quote
collusion narrative with no information
look at shifty Adam shift biggest liar
in Congress look at what he says he
finds that there was no direct collusion
between the Trump campaign and Russia
will you accept that well we're gonna
have to do our own investigation and we
are will certainly be very interested to
learn what Bob Weller finds will you
accept the findings separate from the
investigation that you're doing you know
I will certainly accept them in this way
Danna I have great confidence in the
special counsel and if the special
counsel represents that he has
investigated and not been interfered
with and not been able to make a
criminal case than I will believe that
he is operating in good faith